- [Instructor] A group of
students prepare a large batch
of conductive dough,
a soft substance that
can conduct electricity,
and then mold the dough
into several cylinders
with various cross-sectional areas A
and lengths l.
Each student applies a
potential difference, delta V,
across the ends of a dough cylinder
and determines the
resistance of the cylinder.
The results of their experiments are shown
in the table below.
So what they're doing,
they're taking this material,
this conductive dough,
and they're making cylinders
of different cross-sectional
areas and different lengths.
So they're varying the area,
the cross-sectional area,
and the length, but it's all being made
out of this same material,
and then depending on how they vary that,
you get different resistances.
The students want to
determine the resistivity
of the dough cylinders.
So just as a reminder,
resistivity is different than resistance.
A particular shape of a given material
will have a length and
cross-sectional area,
all of that, will have a given resistance.
But a resistivity is a
property of the material.
And the relationship between resistance
and resistivity, you could write it as
resistance is equal to resistivity,
which is usually represented
with the Greek letter rho,
times the length of the
thing that you're measuring
the resistance of divided
by the cross-sectional area.
And so if you have a higher resistivity,
all else equal, that would
make a higher resistance.
But if you have a higher length,
that also makes a higher resistance.
But if you have a higher
cross-sectional area,
than that lowers the resistance.
And if you were to solve for rho,
you could write rho is equal to resistance
times cross-sectional area over l.
So it then says indicate
below which quantities
could be graphed to determine a value
for the resistivity of
the dough cylinders.
You may use the remaining
columns in the table above,
as needed, to record any
quantities, including units,
that are not already in the table.
So pause this video and think
about how you would do that.
Well I can think of two ways to do that.
You could make a plot,
you could make a scatter plot
where on the horizontal axis,
you put l over A,
and on the vertical
axis, you put resistance.
And then the resistivity
would be the slope of a line
that you try to fit to those points.
So that's one way to do it.
Another way to do it is you
could make your horizontal axis
your A over l
and then you could make
your vertical axis your rho,
and then you could try
to fit a horizontal line
to those points.
Because your resistivity
should not be dependent
on A divided by l.
I'm actually going to
pick this second option
because if I'm doing
this primarily by hand,
it's at least to me easier
to fit a horizontal line
than to fit a non-horizontal line,
as I would have to do there.
So let's do that.
So my vertical axis,
I'm gonna do resistivity, resistivity,
so that's resistivity.
And it's going to be in ohm meters.
And then in my horizontal axis,
I am going to do my
area divided by length,
and that's going to be in meters.
And now to be able to do this,
I need to calculate these things.
So I wanna calculate my
area divided by length,
and I also wanna calculate
my resistivity, rho.
And so area divided by length,
.00049
divided by .03
is equal to
0.016.
So we have 0.016,
two significant digits here,
two significant digits in the things
that I'm dividing with.
And then I can calculate rho
by multiplying my area divided
by length times resistance.
Times my resistance that I measured,
23.6, it's important to
realize that when you do things
experimentally things
aren't going to be perfect.
There's a lot of noise in the real world.
So I'll round that to,
I'll round that to since I have
two significant digits here,
two significant digits here, so 0.39.
So this is 0.39.
And then I'll keep doing that calculation,
and for the sake of time,
I will just speed up the video now.
All right and now we can
move to this second part now.
It says on the grid below,
plot the appropriate
quantities to determine
the resistivity of the dough cylinders.
Clearly scale and label all axes,
including units as appropriate.
So as we mentioned,
on our horizontal axis right over here,
we want to put our
cross-sectional area divided by the length
of our resistors, and
so that's going to be,
we have meters squared divided by meters,
so that's going to be in meters.
And then in our vertical axis,
we want to plot our resistivity,
our resistivity rho,
and that's going to be in ohm meters.
And now we need to think about the scales.
And so the scale of this vertical axis,
if we go back over here,
we see that all of our
calculations for rho,
well it's between around
.3, .4, like that,
or you could say between .30 and I guess
we have up to .41.
So we could have a reasonable scale here.
We have one, two, three, four, five,
so we could say this is .10,
which is the same thing as 1/10.
This is .20, this is .30,
and this is .40,
for our rho scale.
And then for our area
divided by length, we have,
so let's see if we view
all of this in terms
of .0010,
we go between .0038
all the way to .0160.
So let's make this .0050,
0.0050.
This would be .0100,
0.0100.
This would be .0150, 0.0150,
and this would be .0200, 0.0200.
And this would be .0250.
All right I think I have my scales right,
so now we just plot our points.
So let's see the first one
has a resistivity of 0.39,
and our A divided by l is,
which is this is going to be in meters,
this is going to be .0160
of a meter.
So we would look up 160 right over here.
So this is 150,
and then we would wanna go 1/5 of the way
between this and this,
and it's neatly divided
into five sections here.
So this would be 160,
and then I would want 0.39 ohm meters
for the resistivity.
So that would put us right over there.
So that's my first data point.
And now if I go to my second one,
.0098, 0.31.
So .0098 will be right around here,
and then at 0.31 would
be right around there.
So that's my second data point.
And then I get to .0066 and 0.41.
So .0066 would get us,
let's see this would be 60, .0066,
and then we have 0.41.
So that puts us right over there.
Some place like that.
And then last but not least,
.0038 and 0.4.
So then we have
.0038 so this would be
40, this would be 30,
so 38 is like here,
and then we go to .40.
So it is like that.
So those are our four data points.
And then they say,
use the above graph to estimate a value
for the resistivity of
the dough cylinders.
Well as we said,
the resistivity should be constant.
It shouldn't depend on our
area divided by our length.
And so if we wanna fit a
horizontal line to this
that gets as close as possible,
ideally we would have a computer,
but we're gonna hand do it.
We have three of these
points that are pretty close
to .40, but then we
have this one down here,
so I'd wanna get a little bit
closer to these three up there
because there are so
many data points there.
So I would say a line
that looks something,
something like that.
And so this point right over here,
this is maybe approximately 0.37.
So this is 0.37 ohm meters.
I would say 0.37 ohm meters.
And we're done.
And frankly another way
to think about this is,
you could've done it potentially
even without the graph
by saying well look,
a good estimate for my
resistivity of my conductive dough
is to just take the mean of these values.
But they wanted us to use a graph,
and so one technique would be all right,
let's try to fit a horizontal line.
The other technique with
the graph would've been
plotting l over A here and
then plotting resistance
on our vertical axis,
and then our estimate of the
slope of the fitted line,
that would be our estimate of rho.
But that would've been
frankly harder to do
than even what we did here.